try them out while show the trans day of
visibility was another opportunity for
every institution in the country to fall
prostrate to the ground and worship at
the feet of trans people so it was just
like every other day in other words
speaking of which Bud Light has
announced a new partnership with Dylan
Mulvaney Mulvaney is racking up
endorsement deals like a professional
athlete what does that tell us also
leftists claimed that it would cost too
much money to put armed security in
every school in America I have an idea
about how we might be able to free up
some of those funds the prime minister
of New Zealand is asked to define the
word woman and hilarity ensues it never
gets old and our daily cancellation the
rage mob is after me again this time for
they say justifying slavery did I
justify it or are they a bunch of
semi-literate hysterical morons we'll
talk about that try to figure it out
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
the author of the best-selling book Rich
Dad Poor Dad has just cautioned that the
world economy is on the verge of
collapse warning of Bank runs Frozen
savings bail-ins uh He suggests that you
buy real gold and silver coins right now
the recent surge in gold prices is
directly tied to an extremely volatile
Market that's why gold has historically
been a great hedge against the stock
market and against inflation the only
company then that I trust to help you
diversify into gold is Birch gold group
diversification has never been more
important precious metals will always
have inherent value gold is a tangible
and finite resource uncontrolled by any
single government or financial
institution as such they cannot simply
be printed on a government's whim like
paper currency can Birch gold can also
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
into a tax sheltered Ira in physical
precious metals text Walsh to 989-898 to
get a free info kit on gold today with
an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company that I
trust to protect my future and yours
text wall to
989898 today
on Friday our nation once again
celebrated one of its highest and most
sacred holy days the trans day of
visibility it's very important that we
have this special occasion dedicated to
making trans people feel visible you
know there's an urgent need here because
other than the fact that trans people
are relentlessly celebrated and promoted
and elevated and worshiped by every
major corporation and by every
governmental institution and by most of
the most uh you know prominent and
powerful people in our country other
than all that trans people are
practically invisible trans people are
indeed horribly marginalized that is if
you don't take into account the trans
Pride flags hanging all over the place
and you know the trans propaganda shoved
in front of our faces everywhere we go
and the well-funded and coordinated
campaign to promote transgenderism and
recruit our children into it
um putting all that aside
trans people are really getting the cold
shoulder from society I mean if you if
you somehow didn't notice that all of
our most powerful institutions are lying
prostrate on the ground groveling at the
feet of this tiny minority then trans
day of visibility was likely a very
educational day
what I'm saying is that if you happen to
have been walking through life
blindfolded with earplugs for the past
decade or so then this sort of awareness
campaign was made just for you okay then
you probably were walking around on
Friday like trans people what's that I
did never heard of this before
but if you have been even vaguely
conscious and aware prior to Friday then
uh trans day of visibility may have
seemed a bit redundant you know trans
day of visibility that's just another
way of saying it's a day it's and it's
just a day on the calendar
and nevertheless the uh the day was
dutifully commemorated corporations and
Brands paid homage government agencies
displayed their fealty even the National
Weather Service put out a trans day of
visibility statement because no
government agency no institution is
allowed to just be what it is and focus
on uh you know fulfilling the tasks that
it was that it was made to fulfill no
because the the primary uh Duty now of
every institution is to
show their support and loyalty to the
LGBT alphabet soup and especially trans
people of course Joe Biden issued a
presidential Proclamation which somehow
manages to be even more ingratiating and
groveling than you would expect the
statement is lengthy goes on for
paragraphs and paragraphs but here's a
piece of it he says
transgender day of visibility celebrates
the joy strength and absolute courage of
some of the bravest people I know people
who have too often had to put their jobs
relationships and lives on the line just
to be their true selves today we show
millions of transgender and non-binary
Americans that we see them they belong
and they should be treated with dignity
and respect their courage has given
countless others strength but no one
should have to be brave just to be
themselves every American deserves that
freedom transgender Americans shape our
nation's Soul proudly serving in the
military curing deadly diseases holding
elected office running thriving
businesses fighting for justice raising
families and much more as kids they
deserve what every child deserves the
chance to learn and safe and supportive
schools to develop meaningful
friendships and to openly uh to live
openly and honestly as adults they
deserve the same rights enjoyed by every
American including equal access to
health care housing and jobs and the
chance to age with Grace as senior
citizens but today too many transgender
Americans are still denied those rights
and freedoms
now all of that is completely bogus
they're not denied any of that at all
period but
they he is right that trans people shape
our nation's soul
in a way not the way he intends he's
correct
our nation's Soul has been shaped or
misshaped deformed if you will by its
acceptance and promotion of an
acquiescence to gender ideology it
shapes our soul it defines us as a
nation in fact as far as the history
books are concerned uh quote unquote
transgenderism will be one of the only
relevant facts about our era
you know every era of in world history
is going to be inevitably to be defined
and it's going to inevitably boil down
to just a couple of things
and this is one of our things
it will be the thing that our
descendants look back upon with
astonishment and confusion
so Biden is closer to the markier than
he intended to be
but as we've established every day is
trans day of visibility so it continued
on Saturday in Vancouver where
anti-gender ideology activist Chris
Elston who goes by billboard Chris on
Twitter and he does he's been doing
great work on this uh on this topic and
he's been in this fight for years now he
showed up as he often does to peacefully
counter protest a pro-trans rally and
for him counter protesting just means
that he wears a billboard and in this
case I think the sign said children
cannot consent to puberty blockers
and he wears a billboard and he goes
around he talks to people and that's
what he did at this rally
but while Vancouver Police watched and
for one of the cops anyway smiled Elston
was accosted and then physically
assaulted by a trans-identified person
who knows that he the trans identify
person has implicit permission to act
out as violently as he wants and he
decided as we could see here to take
full advantage of that privilege watch
why do you think that they're getting
that kind of representation I mean it's
uh clearly was aggressive violence
[Music]
these police are mostly indoctrinated as
well
they're afraid of the mob
hey
so
um that's about as straightforward as
assault can get and we had to bleep it
out there so it might have been well
it's probably not that confusing but the
whole crowd was screaming Fu at uh
Elston and then the man with the long
hair and lipstick in particular was
right up in elston's face like six
inches from his face screaming Fu while
he's trying to do an interview with this
uh with this media outlet and um then
Elston puts his hand up and this is what
this is what the you know the the trans
activists on social media are using to
try to claim that this was not assault
at all he's well he puts his hands on
him first no uh Elson puts his hand up
to establish personal boundaries which
by the way you have every right to do
nobody has the right to go up right in
your face and scream at you you have
every right to establish your personal
boundaries and that's what he does he
puts his hand up the trans dude responds
by smacking him in the head and throwing
under the ground
uh he feels entitled to his violent rage
the trans person does and for good
reason because the police think that
he's entitled to it too which is why
they did not arrest the assailant and
even later Justified the attack by
telling Elston and this is on camera
that it was a mutual fight
so if you are accosted by this drooling
rage mob screaming Fu in your face and
then smacking you in the face that is a
mutual fight
as far as the cops are concerned
but this is how we make trans people
visible I suppose by by giving them
carte blanche to do whatever they want
all the time
and they got some more visibility the
following day when uh Dylan Mulvaney
added to his long list of corporate
sponsorships with a new one from Bud
Light well then he announced the
partnership on Sunday listen
hi impressive carrying skills right I
got some Bud Lights for us so I kept
hearing about this thing called March
Madness and I thought we were all just
having a hectic month but it turns out
it has something to do with sports and
I'm not sure exactly which sport but
either way it's a cause to celebrate
this month I celebrated my day 365 a
Womanhood and Bud Light Sent Me possibly
the best gift ever a can with my face on
it check out my Instagram story to see
how you can enjoy March Madness with Bud
Light and maybe win some money too love
ya
cheers go team whatever team you love I
love too
okay
love ya okay break a leg
this is how persecuted uh these people
are I mean all a man needs to do is
announce that he's a woman and he'll be
immediately showered with more
endorsement deals than an NFL
quarterback gets
okay again in fact one of the only
quarterbacks who Rivals Mulvaney's
sponsorship tally is Colin Kaepernick
and he's not even a quarterback
the only good news that I can see here
is that it should be very easy to
boycott Bud Light given that their beer
tastes like rain water siphoned out of a
tin bucket that's been sitting in your
backyard for three weeks I mean Bud
Light tastes very much like malaria and
rust and it also tastes like nothing at
the same time so it's kind of an
impressive concoction in that way but
not one that I would actually want to
consume on purpose the only people who
do want to consume it are Frat Boys or
55 year old bikers and nobody in between
those two extremes like literally nobody
else has ever had Bud Light at least not
in the last 20 years
which makes you wonder who this is meant
to appeal to
Okay who in either of those Target demos
would be more likely to purchase and
drink Bud Light now that a man in a
dress is adorning its cans
I mean how does this make good business
sense
the answer of course is that it isn't
being done in order to sell more
products it's being done as a signal as
a symbol as a sign of allegiance to the
trans agenda
and the way to Signal this Allegiance is
to constantly make trans people visible
even if they're already as visible as
any minuscule minority can possibly be
or has ever been in history
but it's still not enough It's never
enough it can never be enough
and that's partly because progressivism
can do nothing but March forward can do
nothing but Pro you know progress
progressivism it progresses like bone
cancer eating away at its host until
there's nothing left to consume
but also partly because trans ideology
in particular is so flimsy it's so frail
that it's always on the verge of
collapse it's perched precariously on
this Edge and it must be aggressively
propped up all the time every second of
the day
the trans person individually barely
believes the claims he makes about
himself and his own identity his
self-perception is this superficial you
know ephemeral thing it's a lie that he
whispers constantly to himself and he
shouts it at the world it demands that
it be shouted back to him
no other group needs this kind of
support
because no other group is in a constant
state of trying to convince itself that
it exists
now there are many other groups in
modern America who demand special rights
and special privileges and entitlements
but the one thing they don't need is to
be constantly persuaded of their own
existence
and that's the real difference here
now let's get to our five headlights
if you have a family and like I do you
already have plenty of things to worry
about
um to say the least in a worst case
scenario you wouldn't want them to have
to worry about money on top of
everything else we all hope that we'll
never need life insurance but mortgage
companies child care and other expenses
they don't disappear when you're gone uh
life moves on and so do all of the
expenses a good life insurance plan can
give you peace of mind that if something
happens to you your family will have a
safety net so they can get back on their
feet and focus on what's most important
in life policy genius makes it easy to
compare life insurance quotes from top
companies and find your lowest price if
you already have coverage through uh
through work employer-sponsored life
insurance may not offer enough
protection for your family's needs and
it's also not going to follow you if you
leave your job policy genius was built
to modernize the life insurance industry
their technology makes it easy to
compare life insurance quotes from top
companies and find your lowest price
with policy genius you can find life
insurance policies that start at just 25
per month for a million dollars of
coverage some options offer coverage in
as little as a week and they avoid
unnecessary medical exams as well says
the licensed agents can help you find
coverage options in as little as a week
they work for you not the insurance
companies there are no added fees and
your personal info is private your loved
ones deserve a financial safety net you
deserve a smarter way to find it and buy
it head to positgenius.com click the
link in the description to get your free
life insurance quotes and see how much
you can save that's policygenius.com
today
I want to begin with something that
still has not gotten old for me I mean I
made the movie and I literally wrote the
book on it and yet I still laugh every
time I see this every time someone
especially some high-ranking person gets
stumped by the question the big question
uh the question that my six-year-old
could answer with ease and that your
six-year-old or your children could
answer if you're raising them right
anyway this time to the prime minister
of New Zealand who is um who has given
his the chance to offer a definition of
Womanhood the seven at a press
conference uh just uh just just recently
and here's what happens
out of here and how does this government
Define a woman
um
to be honest Sean that's that questions
come slightly out of left field for me
um the
well biology sex gender
um
people Define themselves people Define
their own genders
said that he believes 99.9 of women do
not have penises and I know it's a
strange thing for him to say but given
I'd ask again how do you define what a
woman is well as I I think as I've just
indicated I wasn't expecting that
question so it's not something that I've
um you know formulated pre-formulated an
answer on but
um in terms of gender identity I think
people Define their gender identity for
themselves
there was a little bit of honesty there
that I could appreciate because he says
well I don't have a pre-formulated
answer on this so I'm not it's not very
often that you hear politicians actually
admit that listen I can't talk about
this because I don't have a
pre-formulated answer you could only ask
me questions that I have pre-formulated
an answer on
um and uh you know you get a little bit
of that of that Honesty sometimes from
Joe Biden who will look at a sheet of
paper while he's up supposedly answering
questions and look well they don't want
me to talk about this next I'm supposed
to call on this person here that I'm
being instructed
so a little bit of honesty there
although you shouldn't need a
pre-formulated this is like if someone
said um uh prime minister uh
do you know what two plus two equals
well I uh uh well this is a little bit
out of left field I wasn't expecting to
be asked this I know I mean uh two plus
two it's uh well there's math there's
there's numbers there's math and numbers
and you know people all would answer it
differently
even if you weren't I can understand if
you weren't expecting to be asked that
question
but you should still be able to answer
it just like that because that's how
easy of a question is and but obviously
we should be
I think precise here in uh
and what we say about this because
it's not that he it's he knows the
answer it's not that he doesn't know it
obviously he knows the answer
um but what he can't figure out on the
spot when he can't figure out how to do
is how do you
you can't say that answer because then
the trans LGBT uh Mafia comes after him
so he can't say that so how do you he's
trying to figure out how do I say
something about this
without actually giving the answer
and the amazing thing to me is that
these people still haven't even figured
that out yet
it's well established that they that
their ideology will not allow them to
actually give the right answer so we
know that
and they've been given many
opportunities to come up with some other
kind of answer and but there isn't any
other answer it doesn't exist so that's
established
you would think at least at this point
they'd have come up with some kind of
just like standard workaround uh let me
give a he says he doesn't have a
preformulated answer well maybe at this
point if you're on the left you should
have some kind of stump speech ready for
this
they haven't even figured that out yet
like at this point
how are you surprised by the question
never gets old though
uh I you know I feel like we I could
make another what is a Woman film just
the exact same movie with different
people this time
and it would be almost as entertaining
uh all right
this is from the New York Post it says
Tennessee's Governor plans to increase
funding for school safety posting armed
guards at school in the wake of this
week's um or last week now it's shooting
at a private Christian School Nashville
they killed three young students and
three staffers Republican Governor Bill
Lee made the promise as the state reels
from one of the most violent school
shootings in its history and has more
details emerge about the obsessive and
stalkerish quote-unquote behavior of
shooter Audrey Hale
uh lee told the Tennessee on Friday I
think we all understand when people are
feel for fearful when people are angry
and when people lash out I have the same
emotions myself we have an obligation I
have an obligation to do what I can I
work together with leaders across this
community to address people's concerns
and to protect our kids in whatever way
we can so
the school safety plan is to place armed
guards known as school resource officers
at every public school in the state and
provide funding for private schools to
take similar actions Covenant of course
is private school so
um the goal is to get armed security at
every single school public and private
in the state
which absolutely makes sense I mean it
more than makes sense it's a moral
necessity
it's the most logical thing to do it's
also again it's a moral requirement that
if you're going to send if we're gonna
send our kids off like tens of millions
of kids every single day are shipped off
to schools whether it's public or
private and if we're going to do that as
a society
then there is a moral requirement to do
the to take really basic steps to make
sure that they're safe
uh Dan Crenshaw is on CNN over the
weekend and he proposed something
similar Countrywide Nationwide he
suggested two armed security at every
school in the country I want you to
listen to the Anchor's response on this
though the truth of the matter is if we
had a minimum of of two armed guards or
police officers at every single school
in America you'd probably prevent these
from here on now well you said that's
the truth you said that they're random
the one through line in these deaths is
that they are shootings therefore they
are done by guns and Guns are the
leading cause of death for children and
teens in the U.S so shouldn't helping
save the lives
of children be a top priority for you as
a member of the House Majority
no it absolutely should be which is why
I say I would look to the thing that
would absolutely stop this which is
putting armed police officers at every
school I visit a lot of schools I do I
do talks at various schools it's very
rare uh that I go into a school
especially the newer ones and they don't
have some kind of armed police presence
there at all times so that's a
preventive measure that I know will stop
this and there was nothing like that in
these last few mass shootings there's no
armed guards there
um so the answer is I'm just looking for
actual solutions that would be it so the
answer is more guns no the answer is
armed guards the answer is armed guards
right armed guard yes the kind of guns
that protect the president that protect
you all at CNN is it easy to get into
your headquarters at CNN absolutely not
there's armed guards there there's
single points of Entry I think we should
look at our schools as a place that is
precious uh and and have the same kind
of security that your corporate office
is do that we do in Congress you know if
we consider a place to be important
where our children go to learn every day
it should have the same level of
security as every other place whether
it's not whether it's a shopping mall or
a corporate office that's hard to get
into you're not going to get rid of guns
so my only criticism here that's not
really criticism but Crenshaw is
obviously right about this I wish you'd
given his point his rejoinder there
about CNN CNN's offices I wish he'd
given that a little more time to breathe
make her respond to that there's no
response you can give but
um because that's that's
very important uh to observe it she's
saying well more guns are not going to
make us more safe well yeah but you
claim that but a screenshot points out
the CNN offices where you currently are
those offices are guarded by armed
guards every Cable cable news you go to
Fox you go to any of these places
they're going to be guarded by armed
guards
does that make you more safer less safe
and if you're saying that it makes you
less safe because there are more guns
right you add Arm Security on canvas at
CNN headquarters
um
you're adding more guns you're adding
guns into the situation you're saying
that makes you less safe it would make
our kids less safe and so have you I
mean why don't you start
with what's closest to you and what you
have more control over
so why aren't all people at CNN coming
together and saying get rid of these
armed security guards we don't want them
this is making us less safe okay guns
don't make you safe get rid of the armed
security none of them are saying that
just like of course all the Democrat
politicians who uh talk about the
Gonzaga Vegas they they go to work in
buildings that are guarded by armed
guards they are surrounded by armed
guards you know everywhere they go many
of them
Joe Biden guns are gonna make us more
safe well the uh you know the Secret
Service does he are they what are they
carrying around
hmm
are they carrying around a sternly
worded letters to anyone that might make
an attempt on the president's life
no what they would say would I'm sure
what people CNN would say is well we
need the arms you can't get rid of the
armed security because there's other
it's all these crazy right Wingers out
there that would try to come to CNN
offices and kill us
you know which is which is of course
almost certainly not gonna happen like
if you if you if CNN were to have no
armed security at all
they could continue on indefinitely and
they would almost definitely almost
certainly nothing would happen
because there just aren't that many
people out there that would even want to
do anything like that
and yet there's a chance
it's always a chance that some crazy
person could come and based on that
chance let's have the security
well we know there's certainly a chance
that a crazy person will show up at any
school where kids are and uh so why
wouldn't we have armed security
well once again it's this argument well
more guns make us less safe as if
there's no distinction right between a
gun used by armed security and a gun
used by a school shooter they both have
guns if one person with a gun is
dangerous then two people are double is
dangerous
this is the kind of logic it's exactly
the same
logic you know it's exactly the same
thing as arguing
that because prescription drug overdoses
are a leading cause of death in America
um that means all prescription drugs are
bad
and prescription drugs have no place in
society at all and should be banned
it's it's exactly the same kind of logic
the other rebuttal is that this would be
too expensive so Peter strzok tweeted
this in response to the Crenshaw clip
there are 130 000 plus schools in the
U.S where are you going to find 260 000
armed guards
how much are you going to pay them how
much are you going to pay for ongoing
firearms and tactical training
a 40 000 a year salary lowball but hey
it's just our kids alone costs 10.4
billion dollars
10.4 billion dollars is too much he says
too much
wait a second 10 billion dollars that's
it
since when do we pinch pennies like this
okay when it comes to the federal
government
since what is 10 billion dollars
considered a lot that's it only 10
billion dollars
we gave Ukraine 10 times that
and I agree I agree a 40 000 year salary
for armed guards that are uh being paid
to to protect our kids is way too low
double that make it eighty thousand
dollars a year okay let's make it 20
billion
that's still five times less than we
gave to Ukraine
we give you know it fluctuates a little
bit we give about 50 billion dollars a
year every year not counting Ukraine we
get 50 billion dollars a year every year
as foreign aid
which are just which are just welfare
payments paid out to foreign governments
so we give 50 billion dollars a year it
to foreign governments so they can
ostensibly protect themselves and do
whatever else they need to do
um even though there's really no
oversight we have no idea how this money
is spent taxation without without
representation you know that's that's
describes to a t giving our tax money to
foreign governments that's taxation
they're getting our tax money we are not
represented at all so but
be that as it may
so we give 50 billion dollars a year
to foreign governments in foreign aid
again that's aside from 100 billion we
gave to Ukraine
here even if we pay the 80 000 your
salary to two armed guards in every
school
that would still be half
what we give to foreign governments
every year
if you're really therefore concerned
about the money
and I think for a lot of these people on
the left
it's like the first time in their lives
that they've worried about government
spending on something gross don't have
the money it's too much
yeah
okay well then how about this
we don't need to spend any extra money
let's just redirect okay all that money
that we're giving in foreign aid
redirect that money to protecting
American kids for a change how's that
for an idea
I'd like to see all of it I'd like to
see that's what I would like to see all
foreign aid cut every penny of it to
every country take all of that money and
use it to protect our own children
there's a radical idea
um
daily wire has this report Manhattan
district attorney Alvin Bragg's office
dropped an attempted murder charge on a
garage security uh worker who disarmed
and shot an alleged Thief after the
suspect fired two bullets at the worker
when confronted for peering into parked
vehicles
the incident occurred around 5 30 a.m on
Saturday morning when authorities said
overnight security guard Musa dayara 57
years old approached a man peering in
the cars on the second floor of the West
31st Street Garage and requested to look
inside his bag on suspicion of theft
the suspect Who police identified as
Charles Rhodey allegedly pulled out a
gun and shot the aura twice one bullet
struck him in his stomach the other
grazed his ear as the two men wrestled
for control of the firearm sources told
the post that Dr allegedly gained
possession of the firearm and shot
Rhodey in the chest both member
transported to Bellevue Hospital in
stable condition were placed in custody
pending an ongoing investigation
uh they are the victim here the guy that
was shot in the stomach he was
handcuffed to his hospital bed because
he was a suspect in a crime
before Bragg's office dropped the
Arrow's attempted to murder charge
authorities also initially hit the
security guard with uh charges of
assault and criminal possession of a
weapon
current possession of a weapon because
he took the weapon that was being used
in an attempt to kill him he took that
weapon away and then he possessed it and
now it's criminal possession of a weapon
however following an uproar of news
reports about The altercation a
spokesperson for Bragg's office told
local media prosecutors would back off
of Dr in the bloody Saturday morning
Clash pending further investigation
aiding prosecutors are still pursuing
charges against roadie
so
this was this was the story you know and
it went viral over the weekend
um and initially the story was
they're going to charge this guy with
multiple felonies because he defended
himself first he did his job as a
security guard which is you this is what
he's there for see someone attempting to
break into cars confronts that person is
shot in the stomach
manages to get the gun away from the guy
shoots him because now it's a struggle
for it's a it's a it's a fight to the
death basically it's a struggle for your
life
and the first reaction of Alvin Bragg's
office
used to charge the security guard
and and somehow the criminal possession
of a weapon charge is even that doesn't
carry that wouldn't carry the same
sentence as the attempted murder so
that's like the worst charge but that's
he that to me is even more gratuitous
that's the most gratuitous thing of this
whole entire story
um because you know what that represents
that doesn't just represent
um
uh you know a stupid uh thoughtless like
overreaction or not you know that is
you're looking at the situation and
trying to find every charge you can you
can find to throw this guy you you are
sifting through this to find every
possible charge to throw at him
um and they only drop the charge this
isn't this is uh this doesn't become a
non-story now just because they dropped
the charge they only drop the charge
obviously because of the backlash if it
wasn't for the backlash
this guy's probably going to prison
we live under a regime that will punish
the innocent harsher than the guilty
um that that's that's the world we live
in now
where they have they have more interest
in going after the innocent than the
guilty
and in this case it you know especially
because you've got this Thief
kind of common Criminal
turned attempted murderer
the regime they don't see that as a
threat to them they don't really care
about that that's not a threat to them
just to have some Thug out on the street
shooting people and rotten stealing from
cars and all the rest of it what do they
care
but if they perceive you to be a threat
to them
that's when they put the hammer down
and yeah this security guard and we
don't know anything about is politics
but that doesn't matter in this case
because the fact that he
defended himself
you know the fact that he was stopping a
a crime in process
all of these things make him uh make him
an enemy of the regime essentially
and that's why they wanted to take him
down and they would have if not for the
fact that people noticed and uh spoke
out against it
all right Bill Maher was applauded over
the weekend for this proposal play the
clip he says that there should be a
total media blackout of mass shootings
he wants a complete blackout don't talk
about him anymore let's Swatch the clip
the other thing I'd like to say about
this is we're the media anxiously
waiting on all this information about
the shooter how about we have a a
blackout on the shooters and what they
did you know this is uh
yesterday
was the opening of the baseball season
now in baseball when somebody runs on
the field the camera doesn't show it
they don't give that person any
publicity why can't we at least do that
in this country I don't want to hear
anything about it we know it happened I
don't want to know about I don't want to
know that what orientation this person
is how old they are what their Manifesto
said I don't give a about anybody
because it's just going to inspire the
next one because they all feed on each
other that's true at least the media
could do
yeah except that I think the horror of
it you know that that there were three
children involved and then of course the
adults and and that lives were just
taken just like that without any purpose
behind it without there was no warning
there there's a shock to your system
that's the idea and it's a it's a a
popular idea total media black guy let's
not talk about it let's not talk about
manifestos I have to say I disagree with
it completely uh maybe an unpopular view
I have those sometimes
and um
and I'll tell you why for one thing
objectively somebody walking into a
school and slaughtering people
isn't it's important news like it's big
news and it should be treated that way
which isn't to say that we
sensationalize it but but certainly uh
it needs to be reported on I mean what
what were the bigger stories last week
that we should have been focused on
instead
and part of the story is the question of
who did it and why I mean these are
important questions doesn't doesn't
change what happened or anything like
that but we it's part of the story and
we should know that
and to prove my point okay you know I I
don't like the idea let's it would never
happen anyway but let's just say in Bill
Maher's Ideal World a lot of people this
is our their ideal uh scenario where
something like this happens
and then the media they tell you that it
happened they give you the facts of what
actually happened they tell you about
the victims but nothing is said about
the shooter now the shooter remains uh
you know a non-entity basically
and that's supposed to be you know uh
preferable to what we currently have I
don't think it is and I'll give you one
example to prove my point or to
illustrate it anyway uh the Las Vegas
shooting
okay that one was handled exactly as Mar
and others apparently won we we hard we
heard hardly anything about the shooter
we were never told the motive
and we were told very little about his
life
most people don't even remember his name
like most people there are certain names
of shooters that people remember uh you
know Dylan roof
um
that's a name everyone remembers Adam
Lanza but the name of the uh Las Vegas
shooter actually takes me a second
Stephen Paddock was his name so I
remember it but
um I I think if you went to the average
person shoot they wouldn't be able to
tell you his name
and well that's that's ideal right
that's what we want that's what we want
like nobody remembers him he's he's uh
there's an enigma
but is that actually a good thing
I mean does anyone
actually feel good about the fact that
60 people were slaughtered and we were
never told why
because if you want to know what that
would be like what would it be like in a
world where these shootings happen and
but the shooter is not turned into any
kind of posthumous public figure after
the case and we don't care about the
motive we're never told the motive you
want to know what that looks like well
it looks like the Las Vegas shooting and
to me that is not good you know I do not
feel good about the fact that 60 people
died 60 people were massacred and we
were no one ever said why
um I don't think that's a good thing
and incidentally you know there there's
a bit of an update here I should say
that we were never given a motive for
six years stop it back in 2017. So for
six years we were never told why it
happened
that is until this past Friday so as it
happens three days ago
the FBI dumped a bunch of documents
indicating that and these are the
headlines now if you if you uh go and
Google the Las Vegas shooting all these
headlines will pop up
that are three or four days old telling
us that as a bunch of these documents
came out and it indicates that that
maybe the reason he did it was that um
he was angry
that the casinos in Vegas didn't give
enough perks to VIP customers
that's what they're telling us now
that he was essentially a disgruntled
um customer
who wasn't getting enough perks as a you
know as a as an obsessive compulsive
Gambler and uh as a VIP Gambler he
wasn't giving up perks and he was upset
about that and that's why he uh somehow
got all the all of that uh Weaponry that
whole arsenal you know up uh into his
hotel room and then slaughtered 60
people at a music festival
right
well case closed I guess yeah that was
why six years nothing and then six years
later they say oh it's because yeah he
was upset about not getting uh you know
he didn't he did he didn't get enough he
didn't get enough free drinks or
something
yeah he didn't like uh the sweet study
gave him in the hotel were not big
enough
okay no one buys that obviously it's
it's uh it's absurd
is what it is and it only goes to show
that it's it's not a good thing when
we're not told why this happens it's
also this also means that the
authorities you know the powers that be
can they could it's like it gives them
the ability to hide things to hide
details that are inconvenient to them
and I think everybody certainly has a
sense that when it comes to the Las
Vegas shooting there are a lot of
details that for whatever reason we can
only speculate because all we're left
with is speculation but there are many
details of that shooting that the
authorities decided they didn't want us
to know
why didn't they want us to know it
what's the truth of what actually
happened
we'll never know
but that's what it looks like when
um
these Mass Shooters are actually made
into nameless obscure people
um it's uh it's I don't think it's
preferable
let's get to the comment section
it's all alone
again
[Music]
now it's really hard to trust anything
or anyone these days if you've been
paying if you've been paying attention
to current events at all these past few
years you know that you need to be
prepared for anything there is no better
place to start than by having a supply
of emergency food on hand right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
you can go to prepare with walsh.com
it's prepare with walsh.com and grab
this special price before it ends you're
going to want to move now your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations you can enjoy a wide variety
of breakfast lunch dinner drinks snacks
best of all it's actually delicious
don't put off your preparedness any
longer tomorrow maybe too late you have
to act now go to prepare with walsh.com
save 200 on each kit your family needs
go to prepare with walsh.com right now
that's prepare with walsh.com
all right before I get to the comments I
just want to show you this very quickly
we'll have to put this up on the screen
this is uh some more of what I deal with
at home more public shaming from my wife
but I have no shame I'm not ashamed so
I'll show it to you she came out on the
patio yesterday and uh to take this
picture of me which she tweeted
um with uh you know with a mocking
caption
and because we don't have we're ordering
patio furniture all this stuff with
Patty we don't have it right now and as
you can see I'm I'm smoking my cigar
doing some work huddled under an
umbrella to block the Sun and I've got
my slippers and my purple socks
and that's the scene and listen a lot of
people are making fun of me for this
being mocked pretty ruthlessly
you may not like it but this is what a
real man looks like okay this is high
performance masculinity this is a man at
his peak in his purple socks and sandals
or slippers
slouching under a small umbrella so that
he can smoke a cigar without getting
sunburned that's
that's Manliness
man I like it again but you might not
look you know I always like what it
looks like but that's what it looks like
it's also my wife's fault because if I
could just smoke cigars in the living
room then we wouldn't have this problem
the socks also by the way are uh are
purple for the record they're not pink
but I would wear pink socks these socks
are uh from my sock subscription service
and I'm very proud of them
now this is from uh the Dalai Lama says
I assume not not the one and only
there's about five Decades of
politicians I'd need to see held
accountable and hundreds of crimes I
need to see prosecuted before I consider
charging Trump for anything he's been
accused of
yeah that's basically where I fall on
this Dalai Lama uh you know if we if we
actually lived in some alternate
universe
where politicians are held to such a
high standard of conduct that they're
even being prosecuted for things like
this
then that would change the the
calculation for me entirely but that
would mean that that Trump was like you
point out he would be in a line of
hundreds of people before him hundreds
of policies before him who got
prosecuted for similar things and worse
things
so this is like a again an alternate
universe
where when you're a politician you don't
get away with anything
at all
okay and if you do have any overdue
library books from uh from 1995 we're
gonna we're gonna get you for that we're
gonna try to put you in jail for that if
that's the universe we lived in
then it would change the reaction to
this because then the whole argument the
Trump's being singled out
that would be gone
but that's not the universe we live in
which means that Trump is being singled
out uh it's they're not suddenly
becoming sticklers
oh and also in in this alternate fairy
tale Universe we're talking about
um
you know for this to make sense Not only
would all these politicians be
constantly getting prosecuted for things
but also
uh the D.A who brings his charges would
would still first and foremost be
pursuing actual violent criminals like
he's just charging everything anyone who
steps over the line is getting charged
but that's not the case which tells us
that this is politically motivated
whatever else you think about it
politically motivated there's just no
doubt about it
the people who support this most of them
can barely bring themselves to disagree
with that idea there's this implicit
agreement among everybody on both sides
of this that this is primarily
politically motivated
which makes it totally outrageous
um
Dan says I'm a psychiatric nurse
practitioner I believe that the reason
the suicide rate is so high among Youth
and especially people who identify as
transgender is because they're being
taught that two things can be true at
the same time which is irrational
which splits their mind into an
impossible position
irrationality and contradiction
especially in terms of a person's
personal identity are the causes of this
problem I think there's a lot of Truth
to that I think that
what it does primarily is it creates
anxiety
you know when you're when your mind as
you say is split into this and you have
this internal self-contradiction going
on it creates um it creates confusion
and when you have confusion you have the
unknown okay it's a lack of
understanding and that's that's this
source of anxiety anxiety comes from the
unknown
um and so as I've said before gender
ideology is uh it's like an anxiety
machine it's a it's a anxiety uh Factory
just churning it out
Wendy says it's funny how we can tell
sex by bones even with non-human primate
primates but now when it comes to humans
they're trying to act like it's
impossible
well that's true and uh we can also
determine the sex of of all animals
right there's there's still
we still have not quite gotten to the
point
where
I'm sure we'll get there
but even most of the the craziest
proponents of gender ideology will you
know they're not they're not going to
take any issue if you identify the sex
of a dog or a cat or an elephant you
know or a fish
so there's agreement there that sex is
determined biologically
now I say that but you know infamously
in what is woman but I posed this
question about chickens to uh
to uh uh one of the doctors who does
this stuff and and she said that well we
don't know the chicken's gender identity
but for the most part that's not the
position they're taking right now so
they'll admit that when it comes to
animals
yeah we can tell the sex
but then these people would also tell
you that um almost every single one of
them will tell you that we're nothing
but animals we're ourselves in fact
there's like almost no difference
between us and any any other we're not
even we're not even better
then uh then then we were not Superior
to a dog or a cat maybe we're worse
actually a lot of them would tell us
and yet we belong in this special
category when it comes to sex so for
every other animal we're just like an
animal we're no different you say and if
and for all the rest of them
who want to know their sex we just look
biologically and we can tell
but we belong in this special category
how does that work
like are we are we uh part of of nature
or not or are we these like uh uh
deified beings that hover over it and
and you know belong to this special
category of existence
um and finally Aaron Johnson says Matt
you're exactly correct regarding
reparations truthfully American
descendants of African slaves may not
even exist had their ancestors been left
to survive in Africa well it's funny you
should bring that up because we did talk
about this on Friday and um it's going
to shock you to learn that some people
were a little bit upset by our
conversation and that is the topic of
our daily cancellation
I want to talk to you about something I
don't usually talk about hair not mine
my hair is handsome and Brilliant just
like the rest of me because I use
Jeremy's razor shampoo and conditioner
I'm talking about yours because if
you're not also using Jeremy's
restorative tea tree and argan oil blend
to wash your Mane you're doing it wrong
and you are asking to be canceled
Jeremy's razors is more than Razor
Company it's a Men's Grooming brand that
doesn't hate men they're shampoo and
conditioner along with their exfoliating
charcoal body wash are all made from
high quality natural ingredients right
here in the USA they're sulfate sulfate
free and even though I still don't know
what a paraben is
they don't have those either no sulfates
no parabens but most important of all
Jeremy's Jeremy's razors hair and body
bundles are woke free as well stop
giving your money to woke companies who
hate you head over to jeremy'srazors.com
and check out their shampoo conditioner
and body wash bundles today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
if you listen to The Daily cancellation
on Friday then you already knew that
this daily cancellation was coming on
Friday we discussed the idea of
reparations in particular the plan
proposed in California that would Dole
out five million dollars a piece to
Black residents as repayment for the
enslavement that they never experienced
and that nobody they've ever known or
spoken to has experienced during that
segment I expanded on a Counterpoint
a Counterpoint to reparations that have
been made by a black college professor
named Wilford Riley which was a
restatement of an argument made by
others Through The Years including
Dinesh D'Souza which says that
reparation proposals are incoherent
because they rest on the speculative
notion that descendants of slaves are in
a worse place today than they otherwise
would have been if their ancestors were
never enslaved now if this speculation
is not accurate if they are not in a
worse spot then there's nothing to
repair
nothing to repair for them anyway
certainly we know that the slaves
suffered greatly but the slaves are all
dead so the reparations don't go to them
but rather go to people who again never
experience slavery and so we must ask
what exactly we are repairing as far as
they are concerned
according to this argument which I find
compelling and interesting the more
plausible speculation is that in fact
the ancestors of slaves are in a better
spot today not worse because of slavery
this doesn't justify slavery or make it
okay obviously it simply calls into
question the basic logic behind allowing
a group to literally cash in on
historical atrocities
that's the point
and in an incredibly surprising turn of
events people aren't happy
with this point and this came as a great
shock to me personally as I'm a people
pleaser who always tries to avoid
controversy and conflict whenever I can
uh but it found me this time maybe for
the first time starting is always as
always with the requisites Media Matters
clip our PR reps pulled a two-minute
slice of the 10-minute monologue did not
provide any context
um didn't even clarify that this was a
conversation about reparations
specifically and they posted a clip
which then went viral now for reference
uh we'll we'll play the actual video
they posted uh so that you understand
where we are what we're talking about
for the rest of the conversation which
again is just one small sliver of a much
longer monologue where I flesh out all
these points and also explain why I'm
making the points and what the overall
point is but Media Matters never bothers
with silly things like context and they
also know that the drooling hordes who
get worked up by out of context Clips
also aren't going to stop to wonder
about the context
so with that in mind
um here's what they posted
in fact it seems rather clear that black
Americans are doing better here today
than they would be had their ancestors
Generations ago never been brought to
these Shores we can prove this point by
simply asking which African country
anyone asking for reparations would
prefer to live in the answer of course
is none of them now you might offer the
rebuttal that if slavery never existed
if we're reimagining history without
that institution at all then Africa
itself would be in a better shade better
place and better shape and maybe indeed
black Americans would be better off
there but this seems highly unlikely and
it also ignores the fact that Africans
participated in slavery and the slave
trade as much as they were victims of it
not to mention if we're reimagining the
world without African slavery then we
have to also imagine it without all
other forms of global slavery since
African slavery was merely one variety
one offshoot of This Global Institution
and now we have totally in that point
Rewritten the history of the world in a
way so dramatic that it app it's
absolutely impossible to say which
individuals today would end up worse or
better in this alternate universe I mean
if you go back in time and get rid of
slavery from the entire world
you have just it's impossible to say
what the world looks like right now
actually what we can say is that we'd
all end up worse all of us today would
be in a worse spot
if uh slavery never existed at all
across the entire globe
because a change that significant would
likely shift the course of events in a
way that would mean none of us would
even exist it would be a world full of
other people who are not us
so I know that I benefit today from
virtually everything my ancestors did
and everything did to them because if
any of that had not happened there's a
very good chance that I never would have
come into being and as I see it I
benefit from being if the other option
is not being
well you can already uh imagine the
reaction so we don't need to read
through very many of these but here are
a few people of the thousands who
Express their outrage at a point that it
goes without saying none of them even
attempted to refute Heath Mayo a man who
calls himself a Christian conservative
and who also happens to look exactly
like his name for the record tweeted
this is Ben Shapiro's daily wire and
increasingly you're just a bad person if
you support this know nothing filth with
your subscription dollars Bernice King
the daughter of Martin Luther King Jr
responded and here it is one of the
reasons why some don't want the horrors
of slavery taught in schools because
they don't see it or Jim Crow as an
atrocity but a grotesque statement an
egregious insult to the countless
Africans who perished in the Atlantic or
were enslaved here of course race
hustling shell Roland Martin got his two
cents in this analysis by Matt Walsh is
the dumbest you'll ever see this idiot
wants to opine about the condition of
Africa yet makes no mention of racist
white colonialism hell racist whites
redrew the boundaries of Africa at the
1885 Berlin Conference what
Ali kept it simple pro-slavery a hell of
a plot twist a guy named Ryan mcmaken
posted Walsh has been good on exposing
the dumbness of the whole men can be
women thing but there are not words
sufficient to describe how stupid this
statement about slavery is the argument
is the sort of Arcane trivial mental
masturbation I would expect from a
college freshman philosophy major and
given that his apparent Point here is to
basically say stop saying slavery was so
bad it's a totally bizarre Hill to die
on and there was also a lot of stuff
like this when Matt Walsh eventually
dies a hopefully incredibly horrific
painful death it'll be very cool
watching people celebrate
now I actually agree uh with that last
one not the bit about hoping I die
painfully you know I prefer not to die
painfully but the second part um I know
that many people will celebrate my death
and I take great pride in that if I if I
spent my life
fighting against the left's cultural
agenda and then I died and they didn't
cheer over my death and mock me as I lay
buried in the ground
that would be a strong indication that I
was incredibly ineffective
the left will will celebrate your death
if they perceive you as a serious threat
and I certainly wish to be a serious
threat
but that aside
um
let me offer a few thoughts in response
to the responses two thoughts to be
precise
first predictably
everybody in the outrage mob accuses me
of arguing that slavery wasn't bad or
that it wasn't an atrocity or that that
it was actually good
I didn't say any of those things nor did
I imply or suggest them in fact I refer
to slavery as an atrocity in the very
segment where Bernice King says I argue
that it wasn't in atrocity
obviously I believe it was atrocity
everyone believes that it's a point so
self-evident and clear that it doesn't
even need to be said
okay it's actually it's it's a it is a
pointless thing to even say because
everyone knows it
there is not a pro-slavery faction in
the modern United States
so there's no need to continually assure
each other that slavery was bad did you
know you know slavery was bad yeah I
heard it's bad it's really bad very very
bad it's all bad it's really bad we know
that it's one of the few things that we
all still know
so when the Pitchfork mob accuses me of
holding the view that slavery wasn't bad
what they mean is that all I'm allowed
to say about slavery is that it was bad
okay they want us to talk about slavery
they definitely want us to talk about it
they want us to harp on it they want us
to go on and on about it just like they
do
but the only thing we're ever allowed to
say is some variation of it was bad
over and over and over again
um if you try to move on to the next
sentence
it was bad end of sentence and then
continue and say something else about it
if you try to articulate some other
thoughts if you try to say anything else
about it you are automatically guilty of
thinking that it's not bad
um
in other words if it was bad isn't your
only thought about slavery
then you don't have that thought about
it at all
so either you either the only thing you
think about slavery is that it was bad
or you think it was good
you're not allowed to have you know
you're only allowed to have one thought
per topic
and this is how they treat slavery it's
how they treat every other subject
they have for every every subject here's
the thought you can have on that
and uh if you're going to talk about it
yeah go ahead and talk about it but only
just say that continue saying that over
and over and over again
this is what makes debate and Dialogue
on the national level totally impossible
not to mention incredibly boring
when we're all just repeating back to
each other the stuff we already know and
has long been established
how can we have a dialogue when you
aren't allowed to develop your thoughts
Beyond this was bad very bad it was so
bad it was so so bad it was the bad
thing it was a really bad thing
you know it wasn't always this day as I
meant as this way as I mentioned Dinesh
D'Souza has been making a similar
argument for years in fact here here he
is on NPR NPR of all places because this
is the kind of thing you used to be able
to say on NPR
22 years ago
um listen to what he says
as a native of India a country colonized
by the British for centuries and as a
person of color living in the United
States I cannot agree with the idea of
reparations
the concept of reparations is based on
the premise that the descendants of
slavery and colonialism are worse off as
a result of those historical crimes
in reality these descendants are vastly
better off than they would have been had
slavery and colonialism never occurred
let me explain
when I was a young boy growing up in
Bombay I noticed that my grandfather who
had grown up under British colonialism
had developed a strong hostility to the
white man
I realized that he had an anti-white
animus that I didn't share
this puzzled me why did he and I feel so
differently
finally I figured it out the reason for
our difference of perception was that
colonialism had been pretty bad for him
and pretty good for me
another way to put it is that
colonialism had injured those who lived
under it but paradoxically it proved
beneficial to their descendants
virtually everything that I do and
cherish has been shaped by a worldview
that was brought to India by colonialism
I write in English I work on a computer
I believe in individual dignity in human
rights in democratic government
inequality before the law in the concept
of innocent until proven guilty all
these things are the product of Western
Civilization
now again
NPR you could say that 22 years ago
now it's the sort of thing that you'll
only ever hear uttered on conservative
media and even there most the time not
and if you do hear it it's shocking it's
utterly shocking now leftists of course
disagreed I would imagine many of them
did
um with that at the time but there
wasn't any nuclear explosion of mindless
outrage with a bunch of slobbering
dummies screaming you support slavery
you think slavery is good
people understood the point that he was
making because it is at a minimum valid
and logical and thoughtful
it also happens to be self-evidently
true
but these days thanks to social media
thanks to the increasing derangement of
the left thanks to plummeting IQ stores
and scores and all the rest of it
um you cannot make valid and logical
arguments because a valid and logical
argument requires you to develop a
thought beyond the one simple shallow
slogan that the left demands we all
consign ourselves to
second you can somewhat understand the
less confusion here I suppose they
firmly believe that the ends justify the
means that's one of the core beliefs of
their ideology the ends justify the
means so
um
when they hear this discussion they
assume that I'm making an ends justify
the means arguments
because if they were making the argument
that's what they would be doing
if I'm saying that people today have
benefited from historical atrocities I
must be saying that the atrocities were
actually good and Justified because
that's how they think
but that's not how I think
okay I think that there are no results
that could ever retroactively justify an
evil Act
let me give you an example
if I were to shoot you and send you to
the hospital and you don't die and while
you're at the hospital they you know
because they're doing all these tests
and everything they happen to discover
incidentally that you have an aggressive
form of cancer and so they treat the
cancer and you survive
my attempted murder does not
retroactively become a form of medical
treatment
okay it does not become good
now it's true that if I hadn't shot you
you never would have discovered your
cancer perhaps and then or maybe you
discovered it too late
so paradoxically me shooting you
resulted in saving your life
but it was still an act of objective
evil to shoot you
okay so that's the way that works now
here's the thing
if expanding the analogy
if after having your cancer treated you
go on to have children
and then your children have children and
your children's children have children
and many years down the line your
descendants try to sue my descendants
for the generational trauma caused by my
assault against you
well if that were to happen then in that
case it would suddenly become relevant
to point out
that these people claiming damages
decades and decades removed from the
incident probably wouldn't exist their
entire family tree would be erased if
not for the evil act that they are now
trying to cash in on
that's the Crux of it
okay the point that you have most likely
benefited from historical evils becomes
relevant when you attempt to quantify
and monetize the trickle-down harm that
you claim the historical evil has done
to you
it's at that juncture that someone needs
to make the obvious point
this thing that happened long ago was
very very bad it was very bad for your
ancestors it is not however very bad for
you yet you are the one claiming
quantifiable and financial harm
the reparations demands are what makes
this point especially relevant but but
even without reparations there's still
value in acknowledging what we're
talking about here and thinking about it
yes it is true that you likely would not
be here today if history had not
unfolded exactly as it did right the
butterfly effect
The Good the Bad the Ugly the atrocious
all of it led to you and to me
rewrite history and you will have
written us out of the book completely
aside from disqualifying any reparations
demand which I think it does completely
what else does that mean for you well it
simply means that we shouldn't live our
lives obsessed with wrongs committed
long ago consumed by resentment over
ancient sins
it doesn't mean those sins were not sins
okay it doesn't mean that the wrongs
were actually right
it just means that we should stop trying
to make ourselves the victims of the
very events that resulted in our
existence our existence and the most
prosperous and comfortable civilization
in history I might add
we should in a word move on with our
lives
the lives that we are blessed to be
living
because what else is there to do
but just keep living in the moment in
today
that's the point and that's also why the
outrage mob is today once again canceled
that'll do it for this portion of shows
move our members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you on uh tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign